vous aviez des gens on y reste analysé
prévu à l'avance les gens ils doivent
aller bosser ils doivent rentrer chez
eux et fermer leur gueule et regarde la
télévision alors effectivement ils
veulent faire d'une fête se retrouver
entre eux s'exprimer et tout s'ils font
du bruit ils peuvent pas il y a les gens
autour il y a les gens partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il me semble que j'en mettrai deux
grimpants et puis deux jours
une question de d'alliance de couleur
est-ce que l'on peut se servir de la
terre de l'année précédente en rajoutant
du fumier ou du terreau enfin quelque
chose qui l'enrichit qui permet aux
fleurs de trouver leur substances et
bien certaines personnes madame le font
mais en fait il est préférable surtout
si c'est des primaires vous avez
conservé de changer la terre de mettre
une terre comme une neuve
vidéo
vous avez gagné voulu au frais
la bise voilà
c'était une leçon de jardinage dans un
grand ensemble notre premier rencontre
avec les habitants de Massy dans la
banlieue sud de Paris notre première
surprise
grand ensemble une drôle d'expression
inventée voilà 12 ans pour désigner
quelque chose de d'inconnu pas tout à
fait une ville et beaucoup plus qu'un
quartier
réputation franchement mauvaise on avait
tant parlé du mal des grands ensembles
que nous arrivions à Massy avec des
mines de circonstances pour ausculter un
malade
vous aimez ce quartier que vous habitez
madame oui très bien vous pouvez
profiter de ce
ce balcon oui on
est presque tous les soirs et les
avoir oui ça ne vous dérange pas du tout
non absolument pas je les vois mais je
ne les entends pas
et puis enfin je me plais beaucoup parce
que d'abord je suis dans une très belle
avenue
le super centre Paris Sud est juste là
nous avons 72 magasins vous pouvez faire
tous vos achats très très bien desservé
nous n'avons pas besoin d'aller à Paris
pour ça et vous n'avez pas envie vous
d'aller faire des achats ailleurs que
dans votre quartier non je me trouve
très très bien ici très bien d'ailleurs
je suis revenue d'assez loin pour pour
venir ici j'ai préféré Massy à la Côte
d'Azur je m'ennuyais terriblement à Nice
j'avais voulu partir à Nice pour faire
plaisir à mon papa qui malheureusement
est mort avant mon départ et puis une
fois installé à Nice ni mon mari ni
moins ni mes enfants n'avons pu rester
nous avons passé 8 mois et vraiment
Massy Anthony le grand ensemble tout ça
me manquait
bien sûr c'est la Côte d'Azur c'est le
soleil mais voyez le soleil je trouve
qu'il est dans les cœurs
vous êtes fait aucun ami aucune relation
euh non non
pas beaucoup pas beaucoup je l'ai pas
trouvé la chaleur que j'ai trouvé ici à
Massy Anthony bien sûr dans le grand
ensemble
nous allons refaire une commande de
fleurs voilà de fleurs pour celles qui
n'en n'ont pas eu Pétunia
alors madame carsati n'a pas toujours
été aussi rieuse elle est arrivée à
Massy en 1962 avec beaucoup d'autres
rapatriés d'Algérie mais quand on vient
d'Oran comment peut-on s'adapter à Massy
mon impression première en arrivant à
Massy c'est une impression de solitude
d'isolement de tristesse
et surtout en arrivant monsieur personne
non personne
c'était difficile au début de connaître
des gens ici oui quand même c'est normal
quand on quand on habite un endroit
en tant qu'on commence et bien c'est
normal de se faire des amis
qu'est-ce qui vous a aidé en sortir
comment ça s'est passé
et bien ce qui m'a dit en sortie à
sortir de cet état de tristesse dans
laquelle je me trouvais plongée pendant
pendant deux années presque c'est c'est
un club de femmes qui s'appelle le club
maman bien sûr et qui m'a apporté tout
ce dont j'avais besoin c'est-à-dire la
joie
[Musique]
un dérivatif un grand dérivatif que
j'avais besoin mon équilibre j'ai
retrouvé mon équilibre
et puis
des distraction une femme a besoin un
besoin de se distraire un petit peu
naturellement quand elle le peut mais il
faut qu'elle puisse le faire parce que
on a nos occupations toutes d'ailleurs
on a toujours à faire dans une maison
mais il faut se sortir un petit peu de
ces marmites de ces casseroles et puis
de son travail quotidien qui qui a force
à force est une routine et ça vous a
permis de vous faire des amis ça m'a
permis de rencontrer des femmes
charmantes qui m'ont beaucoup appris
vous avez l'impression d'apprendre
quelque chose en allant oui on apprend
beaucoup de choses on apprend beaucoup
de choses on se connaît on connaît les
unes on connaît les autres et puis nous
avons des conférences qui sont très
instructives
par exemple Marcel Segal
qui m'a beaucoup intéressé parce qu'elle
parlait surtout du couple c'est une
chose quand même qui nous touche de près
et puis enfin
le club m'a beaucoup apporté
[Musique]
les poissons
les fleurs la pêche aux truites le
bonheur de Madame carcenti rien de tout
cela n'existerait sans cette petite dame
discrète et active madame Robert
tout le monde vous le dira à Massy le
club maman c'est elle
un grand-père une grand-mère c'était
rare dans les premiers plantes du grand
ensemble on attribuait les appartements
ici qui a des couples avec de jeunes
enfants Monsieur et Madame pinotto coupe
le mascotte du club maman sont de toutes
les sorties
[Musique]
comment il s'appelle
la famille de Madame Robert cinq enfants
un petit chien et un lapin blanc
[Musique]
vous savez que depuis j'ai toujours eu
beaucoup d'activités et finalement ils
ont été élevés au milieu de ces
activités
c'est pour ça tout ce coordonne assez
bien enfin il y a des moments de coup
dur mais enfin on arrive assez bien oui
les enfants il faudra les mettre au
couvert vous êtes gentil une fille
fermez votre jeu et vous allez mettre la
couleur tu vas Agnès
oui ça va faire bientôt 11 ans
oui ma chérie en arrivant ici j'ai
exercé pendant plusieurs années alors
à domicile je faisais des piqûres des
semaines à domicile
que qu'il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
désarroi et beaucoup d'ennuis
en 1964 nous avions déjà rencontré
Madame Robert à Massy son fils aîné avec
4 ans le grand ensemble aussi il était
en pleine crise de croissance
j'ai vu des femmes à qui il a fallu
faire faire des cures de sommeil
vraiment oui la dépression nerveuse
maladie mais c'est des femmes qui
pleurent toute la journée
qui voit rien que des bâtiments rien que
des grues des grues partout pas de
magasin enfin
le grand centre commercial était en
construction on l'attendait avec
impatience depuis quatre ans la cabane
des associations familiales une autre
cabane pour le centre sportif
mais ni maison de la culture ni piscine
ni gare ni autobus c'était en 1964 il y
a 8 ans
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de femmes même
à reprocher à leur mari de les avoir
enterré presque vivant dans
parce qu'en plus tout était un chantier
alors rien n'était agréable on pouvait
même pas se promener on ramener la
bouchée soit en fait c'est
c'était très difficile
c'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée de
fonder le club je crois oui oui je pense
qu'il fallait surtout chercher quelque
chose de concret faire des choses des
réunions
avec des sujets concrets parce que
beaucoup de femmes ne veulent pas à
sortir de chez elle et se sentent
coupable de sortir de chez elle alors
finalement
lorsqu'elles viennent à une réunion
enfin pouvoir leur donner des idées
pratiques
on s'est rendu compte que finalement
c'était bien
alors c'est tout de suite le plus de
succès c'était comment
fleurir fleurir les balcons comme nous
avons toutes des balcons plus ou moins
alors
l'idée des fleurs sur les balcons ah oui
oui et qui toujours chaque année
remporte le même succès et
je pense que bien sûr club maman c'est
ça fait sourire souvent mais enfin
je crois que
ça veut bien dire ce que ça dit
quand je suis pressé nous a dit Madame
Robert je ne fais pas mes courses au
centre commercial je connais trop de
monde on m'arrête à chaque fois
vous allez bien
la semaine prochaine
le samedi c'est très animé le dimanche
aussi parfois j'en ai toujours tous les
enfants oh oui quand c'est le samedi oui
ça fait un petit peu un but de promenade
ça se termine très souvent par un tour
de la neige
[Applaudissements]
représente assez bien une certaine
population du grand enfant jeunes
ingénieurs non conformiste
pendant trois ans j'ai travaillé au
cerdia c'est le début de ma vie
professionnelle et va servir ses centres
d'enseignement de recherche pour les
industries alimentaires et j'habitais à
Paris
et je venais travailler là et de je
faisais aussi des courses dans ma site
dans un temps et tous les jours je
voyais monter je voyais bouger cette
ville je voyais se construire cette
ville j'étais très très excité enfin
très intéressant très curieux de voir
comment est-ce que ça allait comment
est-ce que ça les tourner enfin vous
aviez envie de ah oui j'avais envie d'y
habiter
près du travail et puis et puis parce
que ça me
ça me passionnait en fin de voir quelque
chose de complètement complètement neuf
où tout était à faire on n'y avait pas
de structure de ville rétablie
[Musique]
et alors dès qu'on s'est marié on est
venu y habiter et comment vous vous
trouvez en arrivant qu'est-ce que vous
avez trouvé comme ville était
certainement pas je fais c'est pas je
fais et c'était c'était extrêmement
sympathique parce que précisément les
gens venaient d'ailleurs forcément ils
étaient tous nouveaux ici il y avait il
y avait une très bonne ambiance enfin
il était facile d'entrer en contact avec
les gens
et là encore il s'est vérifié qu'il y
avait aucune structure sociale très
forte de ville ancienne
ça nous a beaucoup plu il y a une chose
qui nous a beaucoup frappé quand on est
arrivé très très quelques semaines après
notre arrivée on était mis à la porte de
chez nous et la porte a claqué fait la
porte du paliers à claquer et il était
impossible de d'ouvrir la porte et en
une heure il y a six ménages qui nous a
invités à dîner à accoucher alors qu'en
fait on connaissait pratiquement
personne il en a trouvé les gens très
accueillants très
ça nous a frappé alors que on aurait été
perdu dans une grande ville ça aurait
été très différent certainement et vous
qui avez habité madame dans une ville
province puisque Versailles on peut dire
c'est une ville de province est-ce que
vous vendez une différence entre la vie
que vous avez menée ici et la vie que
vous auriez pu mener à Versailles je
crois certainement certainement
en ce sens que Versailles est une ville
qui existe depuis très longtemps et
alors que les gens arrivent à Massy
enfin venaient venaient de partout
était prêt à faire à créer quelque chose
à inventer quelque chose à la différence
d'une ville déjà établie
quand même un petit peu prisonnier de
certaines structures existent alors
qu'ici tout était tout était possible on
pouvait créer un vanter n'importe quoi
j'ai l'impression que ma scie c'est une
ville dortoir on appelle si souvent les
grands ensembles je crois que pour
beaucoup de gens c'est une ville de toi
pour nous certainement pas mais pour
beaucoup de gens soit parce que ils sont
trop fatigués quand ils rentrent le soir
avec les transports et tout et puis qui
part très tôt le matin il est pas
possible pour eux d'avoir beaucoup
d'activités soit beaucoup parce que
parce qu'ils ont pas le goût de se
retrouver avec d'autres gens
pour nous pour nous on y a trouvé
beaucoup de gens beaucoup d'amis surtout
beaucoup d'activités
quand même de pas mal de choses plus ou
moins fondre enfin c'est plutôt beaucoup
de choses
ce qu'on veut peut-être dire c'est
casser vite ce qui nous a permis de nous
intégrer c'était la chorale d'accord
chorale du centre culturel pour nous
c'était vraiment vraiment le moyen de
connaître des gens beaucoup de nos amis
sont maintenant des gens de la chorale
pour les enfants il y a énormément il y
a une vie de quartiers qui est autour de
l'école c'est pas grave un quartier à
massive il a densité de la population je
trouve ça fait vraiment penser à la vie
d'un village
[Musique]
pourquoi n'y a-t-il que deux cafés dans
tout le rang ensemble
la loi prévoit qu'on ne peut installer
un café à moins de 300 m d'un
établissement sportif d'un lieu de culte
d'une école il y en a tant paraît-il la
Massy qu'il est impossible sans
dérogation d'ouvrir un nouveau café
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le drugs store jour et nuit on retrouve
là des jeunes qui vivent en marge de
toute activité organisée on n'a pas
envie d'avoir la même vie que les les
adultes de 40 ans qu'est-ce que vous
faites ici par exemple le dimanche ou le
samedi si vous ne travaillez pas
le samedi et le dimanche bon soit on
reste ici on va se balader à Paris comme
ça mais si vous n'avez rien à faire non
on s'en aille journée et qu'est-ce qu'il
y a un massif pour faire quoi que ce
soit sur le seul endroit où les jeunes
peuvent se regrouper ou on connaît tout
le monde c'est le drogestar c'est le
café vous savez qu'ici à Massy c'est il
y a plus de 100 associations de diverses
de gens de femmes
vous les connaissez ou pas qu'est-ce
qu'ils font si il fait je sais pas c'est
des clubs
ils font de la poterie ils font les
femmes se retrouvent l'après-midi pour
aller
se balader ou faire des choses ensemble
je sais pas moi j'ai pas envie d'y aller
ce appareil chose de mort ça m'a pas
quelque chose de vivant et ça me donne
absolument aucun ami de galet vraiment
j'ai pas envie de mettre les pieds quand
je mettais les pieds à des trucs comme
ça amusant de jeunes ou ailleurs je fuis
vite fait quand on rentre il y a un
gardien uniforme et tout comme ambiance
ça nous intéresse pas maintenant les
autres jeunes c'est quelque chose de un
endroit rationalisé aussi ou vraiment
maintenant il est tenu entre les mains
de la mairie et on peut plus s'exprimer
un peu plus rien faire là-bas il faut
passer de montrer patte blanche et tout
donner prendre des cartes puis se passer
des choses sérieuses c'est tout à chaque
fois c'était le directeur qui organise
le truc bon alors c'est lui qui
dirigeait tout quoi puis nous on doit se
tenir calme et tout pour le droit de
toute la vie des gens on ira cette
analysé prévu l'avance les gens ils
doivent aller bosser puis de rentrer
chez eux et fermer leur gueule et
regarde la télévision alors actuellement
ils veulent faire d'une fête se
retrouver entre eux s'exprimer et tout
s'ils font du bruit ils peuvent pas il y
a des gens autour il y a les gens
partout alors dans ce cas là c'est fini
son lieu de fermer leur gueule c'est
vraiment ils sont obligés à faire ça en
fait on veut briser toute leur
créativité toute leur vie on est aux
oblige à se [ __ ] dans leur cage et
puis à s'écraser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un de ces groupes organisés refusé par
les jeunes faites un film sur les
motards de Massy
je parle au maximum quoi selon les
finances bien sûr mais je reste rarement
à massif
aucune autre distraction ici
cinéma
pas grand chose du sport un peu de sport
généralement je ne fais que de la moto
c'est pas drôle comme vie pourquoi on
vit ici seulement pour y dormir et c'est
tout il y a pas de distinction par
exemple effectivement il y a quasiment
pour je sais pas combien de milliers de
personnes qu'est-ce que vous préférez
sacrifier pour faire de la moto
mieux nous connaissions Massy et plus la
vérité se dérobait
nous avons retrouvé chez l'actuel
animateur du centre culturel un pionnier
lui aussi des incertitudes qui
ressemblaient étrangement à celle de ces
jeunes gens insatisfaits mais formulé
avec plus lucidité
on a l'impression qu'on a c'est que les
choses ont assez brutalement définitive
évoluer depuis
mettons un an enfin à côté
et qu'un particulier actuellement c'est
cette vie à massive pour appeler la
vraie vie à Massy en train de
disparaître alors ça aussi c'est
peut-être un petit peu
paradoxal d'aller dire on a cherché des
équipements on a couru après les
équipements pendant 5 ans 10 ans et puis
quand ils sont là on se trouve
finalement peut-être un petit peu des
emparés et les gens
une certaine tendance finalement à être
à y consommer puisqu'il y a tout ce
qu'il faut pour consommer donc être plus
passif et d'autre part certainement
la municipalité et je crois que ce n'est
pas valable seulement pour mes signes et
c'est valable dans une très grande
majorité des cas pour toutes les villes
nouvelles la municipalité à partir du
moment où il y a des équipements
importants qui sont en place tiens à
avoir un contrôle sérieux sur cette
sur ces équipements
ce qui a une certaine tendance
manifestement à gêner les initiatives
privées alors que les iniacides ici il y
avait une espèce de d'effervescence
créatrice pendant un certain nombre
d'années et le fait d'avoir un contrôle
trop serré dessus ce qui se passe je
crois les ailes à beaucoup de à beaucoup
de gens ce qui veut pas dire qu'il soit
désagréable de vivre ainsi mais bon ça
sera comme ailleurs et je pense que si
vous voulez enfin si on se rend un peu
dans les généralités
bonjour
Agnès
je pense qu'on est encore énormément de
choses à faire à Massy qu'est-ce que ça
peut devenir
je crois qu'il faut
de d'abandonner un peu de la prérogative
et de les faire confiance à des groupes
qui ne sont pas contrôlés par une
municipalité et c'est à dire des groupes
qui dans un jour effectivement peuvent
se retourner contre vous
du bruit de colle c'était notre dernière
soirée à Massy quelques-uns de nos
pionniers étaient là discutant comme des
vieux amis qui ont déjà bien des
souvenirs comme
[Musique]
alors simplement comme c'est comme c'est
inhabituel un grand ensemble c'est
fatiguant c'est pas c'est pas habituel
comme comme un quartier de Paris et bien
la solitude marque plus alors il y a des
gens qui se sentent plus seuls il y en a
qui réagissent plus qu'à Paris je crois
que c'est pas l'impression que
finalement vous avez beaucoup de chance
ça m'assie que vous êtes un tout petit
peu privilégié par rapport à d'autres
villes du même type à d'autres banlieues
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
équipements que ça marche ce serait
absurde de dire que c'est sûr
et qui ça serait vraiment enfin moi il
est ridicule c'est équipé normalement
c'est bien équipé je pense que ce à quoi
on doit arriver dans les années qui
viennent bah si ou bien ça va être une
ville de
de gens endormi avec à la tête
quelques quelques tables comme une
vieille ville de province et ou bien ce
sera une ville d'adulte une certaine
conscience de ce qui sent
moi je crois qu'actuellement on est un
peu en balance entre les deux on fait à
mon avis n'est pas une ville d'Orléans
[Musique]
les villes nouvelles dans les années qui
viennent
[Musique]
dépenses qu'on appelle le modèle
a été
un bonheur qui se construit difficile de
dire qu'il sera limité on le saura plus
tard
toutes les fois que je laissais
apparaître le mal que je pouvais penser
de ma scie vous m'en disiez du bien mais
je crois que la personne
c'est vrai en fait tout objet aimer on a
on a des sentiments ambivalents et c'est
c'est à la fois
le modèle c'est ce qu'on aime et puis ce
qu'on aime on voudrait que ce soit
parfait et donc on en rejette certains
certains aspects qui nous déplaisent je
crois c'est pour ça qu'on le défend
[Musique]